but if I didn't go about teaching my
children tradition and culture it'll be
a whole Gap in that we might not be able
to get back then my family and be lost
to the tradition and culture
[Music]
good little spot back here to Sisters
Beaver Dam blocking it but there's
enough water flowing over it to where we
can jump it
[Music]
oh my God
can we do that again no I don't know
this boat that I got last year I was
able to sell a bunch of mammoth ivory
buy a nice big 150 motor and it's got a
jet on there I'm able to drive in some
pretty skinny water this boat is
specially designed for the smaller
Rivers up here in a locket what the dog
look at that we're out he's hunting just
like us
holy cow moves
[Music]
oh a little
cool cab
nasty Baba
Generations food right there you know
someday my kids might be hunting those
calves with their nice big strong Bulls
we don't shoot swans when they're paired
up like that they mate for life if you
kill one of them that other one's just
gonna fly around and uh it quit eating
and just die of a broken heart that's a
happily married couple I don't want to
jump in between that
I think we've been out for at least 24
hours I'm not totally sure hard to tell
when the sun doesn't really go down
we're just gonna keep on trying it'll
open up wider here pretty quick
oh
one more media down to Chunk we really
gotta get up some speed to get over this
next damn I don't know about this
foreign
[Music]
beavers
oh my goodness
time to rip some of this sticks out of
this paper down
having the kids out in the boat it is a
safety hazard this is Springtime the
rivers are just right above the freezing
we've got a lot of water in them they
get a lot of water and they get heavy
and they start flowing really fast
oh
not only the English life
[Music]
I'm glad it's broken now it's great to
see there's a lot of water flowing
through it now
and if we can get
some speed we can make it through it I'm
sure
all right hang on you guys
[Music]
that was pretty wild
oh
hard times don't last forever
strong people do though
fear yeah go ahead Terry
good shot thanks
canvas back
ah
300 miles away from the ocean we get to
eat something from the ocean
it's pretty special
[Music]